so as part of my day job I lead the
database team achieve and so in order to
do my job effectively so for my day job
I have to optimize a petabyte scale
Postgres cluster and so in order to do
my job effectively I need to be super
familiar with the ins and outs of sequel
and all the different kinds of tricks
you can do so I'm going to show you how
you can use some of the techniques I'm
familiar with to generate fractals with
sequel so just a brief overview of
sequel
so in sequel you operate on lists of
rows which you can also call a table
this table represents a list of books so
in a table you have some set of fields a
title author and cot so for books every
book has a title author and cost and you
can see for each book the corresponding
values of those fields and so the most
basic operation you perform on a table
is a select statement which is give me
these fields from the table so in this
case we're asking for the title and
author from the books table and we get
the title and author of every book now
an operation I'm going to be using a ton
throughout this presentation because it
makes sequel queries a lot more legible
is a CTE which is a way of defining
variables in sequel so in this case
we're defining the we're defining Dan
Brown books to be the result of running
the query that gets all books authored
by Dan Brown and then you can use this
you can use dan Brown books as if it
were a natural table later in the query
so below we select the number of Dan
Brown books by using dan brown books
which refers to the results of the query
from before so now that we've gone
through a few basics of sequel and when
let's let's take a look at how we may go
about generating a fractal with sequel
so serpents keys triangle is a very
well-known fractal and one really
interesting way that you can generate
serpents each triangle is with bitwise
and where if you take a grid and you
mark all the points for the bitwise and
of the row number and column number is 0
this will give you some prints keys
triangle surprisingly that's what this
example here shows so in order to write
a sequel query that does this we can do
this in a three step process first write
a sequel query that produces one row for
each cell of the grid and then go over
that and mark all the cells with a
bitwise and a zero and then
I need all the strings together to form
the final fractal so now we can generate
the sellers using this query here we're
using two different Postgres features
generate series and cross drawing
generate series gives you a list of
numbers so we call it once to get the
row numbers and once to get the column
numbers and then cross join takes the
results of two queries and generates
every pair of values between the two
queries so in this case we're using
cross join to get every pair of row
number and column number which gives us
our grid now for marking the points we
can use this feature case when which is
like if-else in any other programming
language and so in this case we're using
when the bitwise and of the row number
and column number is not 0 we mark the
point with a space and otherwise we mark
it with two asterisks and you can see
below that we have marked all the rows
where the bitwise and a 0 with two
asterisks and then we can use this last
look we're here to combine all the
results together it works in two steps
first by combining all the cells in each
row together and using the string gag
function and that uses a string AG again
to combine all the rows into a single
string which is our result and so if you
run this queries it's a 13 line sequel
query not too long you get sierpinski
triangle and so the next question you
may ask is is there any way that we can
reuse the same idea to generate other
fractals and so if you take a look at
the query we had before there's this
slow part here where we use bitwise an
to determine whether or not the point
should be part of the fractal and if you
think about it we can actually replace
this with an arbitrary predicate so for
a given fractal we have some way of
determining whether or not each point
should be part of the fractal we can put
that predicate here and we'll then have
a query that will generate the given
fractal so a well-known fractal that has
this property is the Mandelbrot set so
you can test whether or not a point is
part of the Mandelbrot set by repeatedly
running this formula and if this formula
does not diverge to infinity the point
is part of the Mandelbrot set so in
order to express this definition sequel
we need some way to express iteration
which you can do with this Postgres
feature known as
CDEs so for recursive CTE you specify an
initial query and a recursive query
Postgres will first run the initial
query and then take the results of that
and feed that into the recursive query
it will then take the results of the
recursive query and feed that back into
the recursive query and keep doing that
until the results of the recursive query
returns no results so as an example we
can use this to generate the numbers one
through five so our initial query is
select one which gives us the row one
and then the recursive query is select I
plus one as long as I is less than five
so you take the result from the initial
query one and feed that to a recursive
query that get two and then three and
then four and five and then since five
is in less than five this the query
returns no results and you get the
numbers one through five so we can use
this idea to test whether or not a point
is part of the Mandelbrot set we
repeatedly run that formula from before
a thousand times and then check whether
or not the point diverges or not so we
can then modify our query before from
before but we replace the condition of
bitwise and with testing for each point
whether or not it diverges to infinity
and so if you now run this query you get
the Mandelbrot set
so now the really neat thing here is
that there's actually a whole bunch of
different fractals that use the same
general approach known as escape Time
fractals which are all based on running
a recurrent currents or formula over
each point and using that to determine
what value what care like whether or not
the point is part of the fractal so a
one example is this fractal from the
Julia set it looks something like this
uses a very similar formula to what we
just used we change our sequel query
like this and we get the fractal so
there are a whole bunch of different
fractals that you can use generate using
the same approach I don't have time to
go through them but so this one's like
relatively simple sequel query can
actually generate a whole bunch of
different fractals so addition to the
scape time fractals there's a whole
bunch of other kinds of fractals too so
let's see if we can generate another
class of fractals one interesting class
are self-similar fractals which are
described by taking an initial pattern
and repeatedly applying some rule to it
to generate the next version of the
pattern so in this case we have the
hilbert curve which is a path that
initially starts in the bottom left goes
the top left top right and then bottom
right and you generate the next
iteration of the hilbert curve by
replacing each of the vertices with a
u-shaped curve so for the second
iteration it still goes from the bottom
left to top left to top right to bottom
right but you now have au and where all
the vertices were before and you
repeatedly do this and it gives you the
next iteration of the hilbert curve so
in order to like generate this whoops
equal we need like some way that we can
like represent this and there's actually
a really interesting way they can
represent self similar fractals known as
L systems which are a way of describing
a self-similar fractal as a string so
you start with an initial string that
describes the initial iteration of the
fractal and you have some rule for
modifying that strain to produce the
next iteration of the fractal in this
case for a Hilbert curve the initial
string is a and to generate the next
iteration you replace all the
occurrences of the character a with the
corresponding string and you replace all
the occurrences of B with the
corresponding string so if you run
through the first few times you get this
sequence of strings
and then this string actually describes
the path a path that produces the
hilbert curve where if you interpret all
the s as moving forward all the pluses
as moving right and all the minuses as
turning to the left this pet like path
will give you the path of the hilbert
curve so now really crazy idea let's try
to write a sequel query that processes
l-systems so if we were able to write
such a sequel query we'd be able to feed
in any l system we want and get the
corresponding fractal so in order to do
this we could do this in a two-step
process first write a sequel query that
runs the L system and then a second
query that converts the L system string
into the fractal so ready a query to run
the L system is surprisingly
straightforward we use a recursive CTE
where the initial query is the iteration
0 of the of the L system and then for
the recursive query we run the string
replacement so in this case we're able
to use this Postgres function replace to
replace all the a's with the
corresponding characters and all the B's
with the corresponding characters and so
as you can see this generates the
iterations of the L system now
converting the string into the fractal
is a lot more difficult we can do this
with a three-step process first by
converting the string into a set of line
segments by producing following the path
then converting the line segments into
marked points and then concatenate all
those points together similar as to what
we did before so here's a CT that
calculates the line segments I don't
have time to go through it but the the
rough idea is that a use the recursive
CTE to iterate through the string it
maintains a current line segment and
current direction and based on what
character it is it will update what
character it sees it will update the
state so if it sees an F it will take a
step in the current direction and emit a
new line segment if it sees a plus or
minus it will change the current
direction to turn to the left or to the
right and then from working the points
we can use this query here it works by
checking whether the point is an end
point of some line segment if so it
marks it with a star if the point is
that midpoint of some line segment it
marks with a bar or - based on whether
it's a horizontal or vertical line
segment otherwise it marks it with space
because it's not part of the fractal and
we can use the same query from before to
concatenate all this together
and form the final fractal so this is
what the full query looks like it's a 50
line sequel query so depending on how
you think about it that's either a very
large sequel query or a very small
program and when you run it you get the
helper curve now as I mentioned before
we can not only get the Hilbert curve
but we can feed in any else system we
want and get the corresponding fractal
so the dragon curve is a very well-known
self-similar fractal if you've read
Jurassic Park it is in all the section
title or beginning of the sections and
we can just change the replacement rules
and we get the fractal and then same
thing here's another fractal board and
again it has its own l system which we
can just plug in and produce the
corresponding fractal with sequel so
using just a few simple sequel tricks
we're able to write queries they can
just change slightly and produce tons of
different fractals
[Applause]
[Music]
you